ce confinement numéro 2 sera plus souple
mais il ne faut pas se tromper ce sera
bien un confinement
emmanuel macron a donc annoncé qu'il
serait applicable dans la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi
c'est à dire ce soir à minuit et ce pour
une durée de quatre semaines jusqu'au
1er décembre
alors concrètement ce qui va changer par
rapport au premier confinement du
printemps dernier ce sont les écoles
collèges et lycées qui vont rester
ouverts les crèches elles aussi vont
continuer à accueillir les enfants
toutefois un protocole strict et
renforcée devrait être mise en place
la rentrée est de toute façon prévu
lundi 2 novembre le premier ministre
jean castex a aussi annoncé aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée nationale que les enfants
dès 6 ans devront porter le masque
obligatoirement en ce qui concerne les
universités et les grandes écoles pour
elle c'est la fermeture des cours en
visioconférence et à distance devront
être mis en place partout où ce sera
possible pour nos déplacements le
président a confirmé les rumeurs comme
au printemps ils seront limités à
certains motifs aller au travail chez le
médecin sortir son chien se rendre pour
aider des personnes vulnérables faire
ses courses
c'est le retour de l'attestation
obligatoire pour sortir de chez soi
elle devrait être disponible d'ici peu
ce soir ou demain sur le site du
gouvernement également terminé les
déplacements entre régions une certaine
souplesse sera normalement accordée ce
week-end notamment pour les retours de
vacances de la toussaint les commerces
alimentaires quant à eux restent bien
évidemment ouvert ce qui change par
rapport au printemps dernier ce sont les
administrations mairies préfectures bur
poste ou encore pôle emploi vont rester
ouverts au public
également le secteur du btp n'est pas
concerné par la fermeture les chantiers
devraient se poursuivre enfin les
maisons de retraite ehpad restent elles
aussi ouvertes pour éviter je cite les
drames humains et pour les autres
commerces le couperet est lui tombé que
tout ce qui est non essentiels est
fermée à compter de ce soir comme les
bars les restaurants ou encore les
coiffeurs mais le président s'est voulu
rassurant
la émis l'hypothèse d'une réévaluation
d'ici quinze jours pour de possibles et
assouplissement de cette mesure
pour ce qui est du week-end de la
toussaint quelques exceptions tout de
même les fleuristes par exemple tout
comme les cultes et les cimetières
pourront rester ouverts pour finir les
rassemblements sont évidemment interdit
que ce soit en extérieur mais aussi à
l'intérieur
le président a précisé que les réunions
privées étaient exclues